is the last of us ps5 remake worth 70
dollars the short answer is it's
complicated i am of the opinion that the
last of us is a masterpiece it was one
of my favorite games of 2013 and it
might just be one of my favorite games
of all time you are treading on some
mighty thin eyes here while i love the
gameplay even more so in the remake the
real draw of the last of us is its story
and characters the story in part one is
identical if you were hoping for nods to
the last of us too you are setting
yourself up for disappointment as
naughty dog puts it this is a faithful
recreation of the original game now if
you've never played the last of us and
you own a ps5 then i don't think you'll
regret paying 70 dollars for that
experience there's a reason why the
story is exactly the same as it was nine
years ago it's because it's really
[ __ ] good listen to me
if i get into trouble down there
you make every
shot count yeah
i got this
however and this is a big however you
can technically play the last of us
remastered on your ps5 right now for no
extra cost if you're a playstation plus
subscriber it's an inferior version but
if you want to experience the story
without a 70 dollar buy-in this is
probably the way to go the visuals won't
look as sharp and the combat won't be as
refined but it's still a brilliant game
now what if you've already played the
last of us the meat of this remake are
visual and performance enhancements an
impressive suite of accessibility
options and a bunch of quality of life
improvements basically it looks better
runs smoother and plays tighter let's
start with the visuals
as we've come to expect there are a
couple rendering options fidelity and
performance fidelity favors resolution
over performance with a native 4k
resolution while targeting 30 frames per
second performance on the other hand has
a dynamic resolution and runs at a
stable 60 frames per second i swapped
between both settings during my
adventure both ran great but i
definitely lean more towards the
performance setting especially during
combat there's also an unlocked frame
rate setting if you have a high refresh
or variable refresh rate tv i don't so i
can't tell you anything about it no
matter what rendering mode you choose
though the game looks astounding i don't
know if i'd say the last of us part one
looks a lot better than the last of us
but it's really hard going back to the
original especially the ps3 version
everything just looks so sharp and well
defined the characters are more
expressive and the lighting good lord
the lighting if you're like me you'll be
spending a lot of time in the improved
photo mode part 1 also has an overhauled
weapon crafting menu while the weapon
upgrades are the same you can now watch
joel upgrade his weapons in real time
personally i love this stuff and i'm
happy to see it in part one but it's not
really a game changer though the more
noticeable change to the presentation is
the improved audio and sound design
the 3d audio support gives more weight
to the journey joel's punches sound
meteor
gunshots have a satisfying crack to them
and the dialogue sounds cleaner than
ever yeah i thought you were one of them
too i swapped between headphones and tv
speakers during my playthroughs and the
difference is night and day if you
really want to get swept up in the world
of the last of us i to play with
headphones whenever possible the game
feels a lot better as well the aiming is
responsive the character animations look
and feel more fluid and the haptic
feedback in the triggers makes weapons
feel a bit weightier some combat
encounters have also been tweaked most
notably are the bloater fights the
glowing bulges on the bloater skin are
gone like in the last of us part 2 this
means you don't have to be as precise
when you fight them just shoot them a
lot or burn them and they'll die
eventually unfortunately a lot of the
gameplay mechanics from the last of its
part 2 didn't make it into part 1. the
ability to go prone and jump are the
obvious ones it makes sense given the
last of us environments weren't designed
with a crawling and jumping joel in mind
but since this has been marketed as a
remake i was kind of hoping we'd see
this in part one
the most welcome additions to part one
are its accessibility options and
customizable difficulty just like in
part two the accessibility options are
immense if visual impairments or motion
sickness has prevented you from playing
the original this remake should
significantly lower the bar of entry you
can fully customize the difficulty too
ranging from how common resources are to
how aggressive enemies are as long as
you don't play on permadeath or grounded
mode these settings can be changed at
any time the ai also feels much more
reactive and dynamic especially on
harder difficulties according to naughty
dog they basically lifted the ai from
part two and dropped it into part one
i'm sure it was a bit more complicated
than that but you get the gist
aggressive enemies will flank and
pressure you while passive enemies hide
from view and wait for you to make a
move combat in general feels scrappier
and more unpredictable if you let your
guard down for a second they will take
advantage of it
once you've completed the game there are
a bunch of unlockable extras that
include concept art behind the scenes
videos character skins and gameplay
modifiers like mirror mode and my
personal favorite explosive arrows
[Applause]
some of these extras were in the
original and remaster while others are
spoilery so i don't want to spend too
much time on this just know that there's
a lot to unlock once you've finished the
game part 1 also has a permadeath mode a
speed run mode and a full loadout new
game plus which basically lets you take
everything into a new game it's not huge
but it can be kind of fun taking a
flamethrower into some of those early
fights
the last of us part 1 also makes it a
bit easier to hunt down trophies it
tracks all the collectibles in each
chapter and specific encounters can be
reloaded with ease the save system is
still a bit weird though if you load
into a chapter from a completed save it
will create a new save once you've
picked up the missing collectibles and
returned to the menu it defaults to the
save that you just created and that save
isn't considered complete this means
that you really need to keep track of
all your completed auto saves if you
plan on jumping into different chapters
so is the last of us part one really
worth seventy dollars hopefully i've
given you enough information at this
point to let you make your own decision
but here's my take if you like the story
but you never cared much for the combat
maybe it's better to revisit the 2014
remaster or just wait for a sale i'm
sure eventually it will be included with
playstation plus extra and premium what
if you want to play multiplayer well
you're out of luck i'm not gonna lie i
loved the last of us multiplayer mode
and it's a bit weird not to see factions
on the main menu considering naughty dog
is currently working on a new last of us
multiplayer component which the director
says is as big as the developer single
player games its omission shouldn't be
too surprising but it's still a little
disappointing the package does feel a
bit incomplete without it so i just hope
that when the last of us's multiplayer
component does release fans who purchase
part 1 will be rewarded in some way now
if you're a big fan of this series and
you want to experience it in the best
way possible i don't think you'll be
disappointed the remake offers enough
new features and extra content to make
the experience feel fresh as someone who
plays these games for the combat just as
much as the story i still think it's
worth 70 dollars all these new features
and quality of life adjustments make one
of my favorite games in recent years
even better in fact despite getting a
review code from sony my physical copy
should be arriving in the mail pretty
soon anyway i hope you enjoyed this
video and for more stay tuned to
gamespot let me tell you a story
once upon a time
i had somebody that i cared about
the
partner somebody i had to look after
and in this world that sort of shit's
good for one thing
getting you killed